بسعر الكيلوغرام الواحد يجعل الموقع أكثر
باهظة الثمن في العالم في السوق نستطيع
اعثر على الكافيار بالليمون حوالي 200
300 يورو للكيلوغرام الواحد من الليمون
نادر ولا يوجد في كل مكان
على رفوف السوبر ماركت
[موسيقى]
اسمي إتيان هيت وأنا كذلك
لقد مرت عشر سنوات على رواتب Perrine
مع الأسماء الطيبة معا كنا
أول من قام بزراعة كافيار الليمون فيها
فرنسا لبيع الفاكهة في
كافيار الليمون هو فاكهة لهذه الصغيرة
اللغة الإنجليزية تسميها الإصبع
الجير لذلك يكون له شكل قليلا من
إصبعين مثل هذا وداخله
لا يوجد سوى كرات صغيرة
يأخذ كافيار الليمون اسمه في النهاية من
شكل الكرات الصغيرة التي نجدها
داخل الكافيار والليمون
يشبه بيض سمك الحفش إيبي
هي حقًا مستديرة تمامًا و
نكهة من المواقع ستتدخل جدا جدا
مثير جدا
قد يكون هناك أذواق مختلفة في
حسب مجموعة آجال الاستحقاق
يمكن أن ينتقل من حامض حامض جدا
رائحة الليمون التي أيضا
الموجودة في بعض المواقع لديها فقط
حسنا القرية من حيث هي جدا
مهم لعملياتنا
لأن معدل سطوع الشمس و
320 يوم مشمس في السنة لذا اذهب
السماح لنمو ثمار الحمضيات
استحقاقها أقل من 300 يوم من
أشعة الشمس في السنة الحمضيات
ننسى هذا الليمون وباهظ الثمن لأن
إنه ليمون يباع في أي
أيضا كمية صغيرة من الأشجار التي
هي أيضًا غير منتجة وهو أمر بالغ الأهمية
من الصعب جسديًا هناك الكثير
خسائر على الأشجار كثيرة جدا
من الفاكهة التي لم يتم قطفها
مكتمل تمامًا نحن مندهشون
الثمار التي يحصل عليها المرء
إنه ليمونة ثمينة
الرؤساء الكبار
في الواقع نحن نعمل اليوم على ذلك
تقريبا مع 25 مطعما ثلاثة
النجوم في فرنسا ربما أكثر من ذلك بقليل
نتساءل قليلا كيف هم
سوف يتحول من قبل رساميها
أخيرا ما سبب الطهاة
التي نقدمها لهم
الألوان وسوف يفعلون الرسم
خلف
مرحبا انا دانيال ليترن رئيس
أمضى المطبخ الباقي - 34000
مونبلييه ومالحة لمدة ثماني سنوات
أنا أحب الليمون لها لأنها
العرق بين الحموضة المركزة
الحداثة وفي نفس الوقت تجلب
الأناقة في الطبق لأنها ليست كذلك
ليس مفعم بالحيوية ، أنا فقط أينما كنت
فجر الكرة الصغيرة تحت سوتا
أسنان من ذلك الليمون وانفجر
اليوم أطبخ لك
انها ليست طويلة خردل الماكريل النهائي
النيران وكافيار الليمون
عندما أقوم بتقديمه في طبق فهو
العنصر المركزي هو من يذهب
الاستيقاظ الكتابة على الجدران هو الأكثر
مهم ثم يجلب هذا
استجواب عند القدم في الواقع هناك
هذه الحموضة التي لن تكون بعد
سوف يحضرون الباقي إلى فمه
السباق
كل شيء سيحدث المطبخ الراقي
الكافيار الليمون يجعل الناس يحلمون
عنصر من عناصر فن الطهو وليس
الرغبة المقدسة في النهاية
الذي يتعذر الوصول إليه في الواقع هو الذهاب
للذهاب للحصول عليه
[موسيقى]